there is a direct connection between
your gut microbiome and the strength of
your immune system and for that reason
it becomes imperative that we take care
and nurture a healthy gut microbiome but
to me the most powerful influence is the
stress that actually has an impact on
our gut microbiome and it drives us to
this place where we all sort of have
different ways that we cope and deal
with that stress and for many it's to
turn to unhealthy habits and that
includes unhealthy food and in many
cases alcohol and we're compounding that
stress and we're actually compounding
the harm that it does to our gut
microbiome there's a direct line between
gut health and our immune system 70 of
our immune system lives in our gut and
when we have that emotional trauma
that's affecting our gut and then we
also compound that by consuming alcohol
or by eating junk food we're putting
ourselves into a vulnerable place where
if we do get the virus we don't have our
defense system built up to protect us